Earlier we discussed syntax and
semantics and
said that syntax is structure
while semantics is meaning.
The HL7 Reference Implementation Model,
or RIM,
defines the semantics of a common
set of administrative financial and
clinical concepts in order
to foster interoperability.
It consists of five abstract concepts.
Each happening is an Act.
Examples include procedures,
observations and medications.
Acts are connected through
Act Relationships.
Participation defines the context for
an Act author, performer,
subject or location.
The participants have Roles,
such as patient, provider and so on.
And Roles are played by Entities,
which could be persons, organizations,
material, places or even devices.